Good afternoon. I'd like to thank everyone for coming here.
I'd like to, the AACR Irving Weinstein Foundation Distinguished
Lectureship.
This is a lectureship specifically designed to award
innovation and out-of-the-box thinking, and I'm so excited
by our speaker today, Dr. Lo, who's done
tremendous work
and really laid the groundwork for early detection and
MRD and so many other important areas.
So,
I'd just like to say that Dr. Lo,
we'll hear more about his specific background, but we're
delighted to help continue to support the AACR, who's been a fantastic
partner.
And during these
challenging times, sometimes in the United States right now in terms of
the way forward for cancer,
it's important that we work together and partner.
And so we're delighted to hear
the insights from Dr. Lo. Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you all for being here.
My name's Tim Yap from the University of Texas MD Anderson
Cancer Center in Houston, Texas.
And I hope everyone is enjoying this spectacular
AACR annual meeting.
Dr. Lebkin, thank you so much for that warm
introduction for Dr. Lo.
And on behalf of the officers and the directors of the
AACR board of directors, I would like to thank you
and your colleagues at the Irving Weinstein Foundation for your continued
partnership and generous support of this special
lectureship. Please join me in a round of applause.
Now, the AACR Irving Weinstein Foundation Distinguished
Lectureship was established in 2005,
a long time ago, to acknowledge individuals whose outstanding
personal innovation in science and whose position as a thought
leader in fields relevant to cancer research has the
potential to inspire creative thinking
and new directions in cancer research.
And I have the great honor to present Dr.
Dennis Lo with this year's award.
Dr. Lo is the vice chancellor and president of the Chinese
University of Hong Kong. He also serves as the Li Ka
Shing Professor of Medicine and the professor
of chemical pathology.
He is being recognized with this lectureship for his pioneering
contributions to biomedical science, including his seminal
discovery of fetal DNA in maternal plasma,
a breakthrough that truly revolutionized non-invasive
prenatal testing
and laid the foundation for research dedicated to the study of
circulating free and tumor DNA.
Indeed, Dr. Lo was the first to identify cell-free
fetal DNA, RNA, and fetal
epigenetic markers in maternal plasma,
enabling, say, for an earlier prenatal
diagnostics.
And building on this discovery, Dr.
Lo demonstrated that DNA released by tumors may be used
for cancer screening and diagnosis,
an insight that has since led to the development of
circulating DNA-based tools
for early cancer detection.
And his visionary research has been paradigm-shifting and remains a
cornerstone of precision cancer medicine by
transforming modern approaches to cancer
diagnostics, cancer diagnosis, treatment selection,
and disease surveillance.
And Dr. Lo, personally, as a medical oncologist and cancer drug
developer, I've seen firsthand
the evolution and rapid development of circulating tumor
DNA as a multi-utility biomarker in the clinic and its
massive impact in transforming patient care.
And in addition to his research, Dr.
Lo has contributed to several of the AACR's
scientific journals over the many years, serving as a scientific
editor for "Cancer Discovery" since 2023
and as a past peer reviewer for both "Cancer
Research" and "Clinical Cancer Research."
Dr. Lo's been honored with numerous awards throughout his
career, including the Lasker~DeBakey Clinical Medical
Research Award and the Breakthrough Prize in Life
Sciences. He has been included on "Nature
Biotechnology's" list of top 20 translational
researchers, not once, not twice, not three times, but four
times,
and was previously honored with a Royal Medal in
biological sciences from the Royal Society.
He's also been elected as a fellow of numerous
societies throughout the world in recognition for
his enormous scientific accomplishments.
Dr. Lo earned his undergraduate degree at the University of Cambridge
and his medical and doctorate degrees from the University of Oxford.
So I'm absolutely delighted to honor him with the
22nd AACR Irving Weinstein Foundation Distinguished
Leadership and Lectureship. Please join me now in
welcoming Dr. Lo to the lectern.
So good afternoon. It's my great honor and privilege to be
selected to be this year's Weinstein lecturer.
I'd like to thank the Weinstein Foundation for the support and also
Professor Lillian Siu for selecting me.
So this is my conflict interest slide.
So this is a picture of myself actually taken many years ago when I was
still a medical student in Oxford.
So as a medical student, we have to study different subjects, and one of the
subjects is obstetrics, where I learn about how when a woman is
pregnant, she'll like to know about the health of the baby, including
the genetic health.
But at that time, if we want to test the chromosomes or DNA of
the baby, we have to stick a long needle into uterus
and to obtain some samples through amniocentesis.
But every time we do that, there's a risk that we may harm the baby.
So as a young medical student, I was thinking, is it possible I could actually
avoid all of that by developing a relatively non-invasive blood test
I can actually take from the blood of the pregnant mother?
So I was thinking, is it possible that during pregnancy, a fetus would release its
cells in the bloodstream of mother?
But the question is, of course, if there are such cells, how do you know it's
actually from the fetus?
Then I thought, well, if the baby is a boy, then at that juncture, we
should be able to see male cells circulating in the mother's blood.
So I managed to persuade some professor in Oxford to actually
allow me to do that, and for example, we can then use in situ
hybridization, and you can see that here with the probe, every
time we see male cells, we can see a black dot.
So you can clearly see that in the blood of this pregnant mother, there's a number
of male cells circulating around.
On the other hand, every time we have to do that, then I thought it was relatively
tedious. So I like something which is relatively
automated, so to speak. So at that time, the polymerase chain reaction is
just coming into existence. So I was thinking, well, maybe we can
actually use Y chromosome PCR to detect this fetal
DNA.
And then this result in this publication in The Lancet, just in the year when I
qualify as a doctor.
And then a few
months later, actually, The Lancet published an editorial called "Is It a
Boy?" Because theoretically, you can use this technology to tell the sex
of a baby. And then I graduate and became a junior doctor
for one year. But during that time, I was constantly thinking about
this area because I thought that somehow I've started it, and so I've
responsibility to finish it. And so after one year,
decide to actually go back to Oxford and actually try to do on this
full-time. So it is a picture of myself as a PhD student in
Oxford. I can see that I'm sort of all cover up because
I'm actually using a male chromosome as a marker.
Now, of course, every cell in my body have a male chromosome.
So I try to protect my samples from myself.
Now, but sometimes in life, if you do something
part-time just for fun, you see all the good things about it.
But on the other hand, if you do something full-time, then suddenly all the
problems surface, and this is one of those fields.
So when I start working on this full-time, I realize that even though they are
circulating fetal cells, the concentration is really super low.
It's like trying to hunt for this needle in a haystack.
So after three and a half years of work, I was not able to actually get
a system which is robust enough to be working in a clinic,
and so my grants has finished. So at that time, the science didn't go
well, but luckily, I was able to actually met my wife.
So the two of us graduate together in July in
1994, and I went back to become a doctor
for a few years. And then 1997 came, so that was the year that Hong
Kong went back to sovereignty of China.
So my wife and I thought it was time to actually go home.
So then I joined the Chinese University of Hong Kong.
So this is a picture of our campus in the northeastern part of Hong
Kong.
So at that time, I was waiting actually to go back home, about three
months.
Then in this issue of "Nature Medicine," there were two papers
which says that in patient with cancer, you can find cancer
DNA in the plasma and serum of the cancer patient.
And then suddenly, I have a strange thought, and I thought that a cancer growing in
a patient is actually quite similar to a fetus growing in a mother.
And also rather naively, I thought that I've actually never seen a cancer which is
as big as an eight-pound baby. So I thought, well,
maybe if a small cancer tumor can release enough DNA for us to
see, then surely the fetal side, I should be able to see a signal.
And so what that means is that in the previous eight years, I was looking the wrong
place. So now I'm trying to hunt cell-free fetal
DNA in the plasma of pregnant mother.
But on the other hand, by that time, you can imagine just resigned, and I don't
have a grant, and then I've never worked on plasma before.
So the question is, how do you even extract this DNA from plasma?
And then I recall after my time in various Oxbridge
colleges, I never actually quite enjoy the food there.
So sometimes I actually go and cook instant noodles in my room.
And of course, to cook instant noodles, what you do is that you boil some water,
and you put the noodles in, and then a few minutes later, you have your dinner,
right? So I was thinking, how about if I take some of the plasma serum
and just boil it for five minutes and take a few drops to do
PCR?
And you probably think that it's crazy, but sometimes if you don't have resources,
you have to try crazy things. And indeed, this is what we've done.
And so you can see that even with this very crude preparation, I was able to
actually see a signal in some pregnant mother, a Y chromosome signal,
and some of the others do not have signal.
And later on, I find that all the ones with the Y chromosome signal all have
baby boys, and all the one without all have baby girls.
Oh.
So this is the first discovery of cell-free fetal DNA in maternal plasma and
serum. It hasn't been shown before because previously people was
focused on sorting the cells, and plasma is stuff that they throw
away immediately.And then later on, we find that actually this
cell-free DNA entered maternal blood very early on, like from
six weeks of pregnancy. And surprisingly, by the 10 weeks,
the concentration reaches 10%, 15%, which is
amazingly high because imagine a 10-week fetus is still super small
compared with the size of a mother.
And also, after delivery of the baby, the free
DNA concentration dropped very quickly with a half-life of
16 minutes. And as a matter of fact, so this work actually
established the rapid kinetics of cell-free DNA, which of course now
you see in liquid biopsy is the same thing.
And then we thought, now we have this new source of fetal material, so maybe
it's time to try to convert that into some form of prenatal testing.
Now, the number one reason why pregnant women go for prenatal testing is
because they are worried the baby may be suffering from chromosome
disorders like Down syndrome, which is caused by the baby having an extra
chromosome 21. So we thought, well, can I use this technology that
way?
Of course, normally, you try to diagnose trisomy 21, you have to take the fetal
cells, and then you probe it. Say, in this case, you see there's a
free chromosome 21 signal, so the baby have trisomy 21.
But now we have a problem because in my field, I don't
have a cell. I'm looking at DNA molecules swimming
outside cell. So the question is, how can you actually use this
cell-free signal to deduce what is inside this
cell?
So it actually took me 10 years to work out.
So the answer actually seemed very simple.
So imagine, let's say you have a wallet,
and sometimes you have four coins and some of the other times you
have three coins. And I want to know today how many coins you
have in your wallet. So one way is to ask you to hand me your wallet.
That would be like invasive prenatal testing, a bit
intrusive. But another way is to ask you to stand on a
balance. Now, theoretically, on a day when you have more money,
you should be a little bit heavier.
But of course, the balance has to be super precise.
So let's say that you're 120 pounds, but with one more coin, you'll be
120.01 pounds. So the precision of the balance
is very important. So I calculate that actually if we
use this, so basically we need a very accurate way to
quantify DNA from different chromosomes.
And we estimate that you need the precision to be like 5%.
And this is difficult because imagine in those days, if you use
PCR, which is a doubling process, you can tell 100
molecules from 200, but it's very difficult to tell 100 from
105.
And then we thought, "Well, how about if I do it digitally?" And of
course, remember this work was done way before the
droplet, digital PCR, et cetera. So at this time, we're thinking, well,
in a digital scenario, you basically, the precision of
assay is arbitrary, depends on how many tubes you actually do.
And so after we've done that, for the first time, we're able
to detect directly the presence of a trisomy 21 fetus
in the blood of a pregnant mother. So we published this in PNAS.
But strangely, within a few weeks after I published this paper,
another group actually published a very similar paper.
So you can see that my paper, digital PCR, their paper, digital polymerase
chain reaction. And also, surprisingly, the two papers were
submitted on the same day, which is May the 9th,
2007.
So of course, a good thing about that is
it's likely that this method will work because at least two groups have
independently replicated data. But the tough bit is of course then
we have competition. So basically, two groups are now racing to try
to push this to the clinic.
But then both of us, we met some problems. So what's the problem?
Now the problem is that if you try to use PCR, let's say to measure a
target on chromosome 21,
but if you focus on one gene assay, but there are actually about
150 genes on chromosome 21, you're basically ignoring all the other
information. So the assay is not actually that robust.
So thinking, is it possible we could have a method which will allow me to
survey the entire genome in one go?
And at the time, actually, the next-generation sequencing started
coming into existence. But the first application of next-generation sequencing in
those days are qualitative. So they're asking if this tumor
has this mutation, yes or no. But as
I was thinking, is it possible we could do it in a quantitative fashion,
in a shotgun or random fashion? So let's say we randomly sequence
millions of molecules in the blood of this pregnant woman, and then I
find the origin of each of those, sequence.
And then at the bottom, I can use a quantitative tally to see if any
chromosome has over or underrepresented.
And by doing that, we find that actually in trisomy 21 pregnancy, you can
see the signal is actually very distinguishable from those who are
euploid. We actually look at 28 cases, 14 with
Down syndrome, 14 normal, and they're 100% accurate.
So we're very excited. So we published this paper.
And also, but very interesting, within a few weeks of this paper, the
other guy also published their paper.
Ah.
And I was thinking, "Well, who is this guy?
Why are we constantly competing each other?" So I take a
look, and of course, you can see the last author is the name of Stephen Quake.
So I take a look at his website and find that he's a professor of bioengineering
from Stanford. And also very curiously, he also graduated
from Oxford,
in physics, and also in the same year that I graduated in '94.
So actually, as a turnout, my wife actually studied physics in Oxford.
So I asked her, does she know him? And she said no.
But what she did is that she take out this photoAnd that's Steve Quake.
So you can see it's almost like the person sitting next to you today is the one
who's going to compete with you 10 years from now.
And not only that, a few years later, I was fortunate enough to be elected into US
National Academy of Science. And on the day when the result came out, I saw
my name, and then I saw his as well. So then the
three of us took a picture here at the induction
ceremony.
So anyway, back to science. So now we have this prototype method which
seems to be very robust in detecting trisomy 21 from the
mother's blood. And then the next thing is to push out in the clinical practice,
we need a clinical trial. So I spent the next three years doing, and this is the
result. You can see on the right-hand side is a signal from trisomy 21
pregnancy, and on the left are the normal pregnancy.
And basically, the test is over 99% accurate.
So we thought we're ready.
But of course, I couldn't do that in the university.
If I want to commercialize this, I have to work with some companies.
And also at that time in Hong Kong, it's not very common for
professors to have their own companies.
So we thought, "Well, how about licensing?"
Of course, when you talk about licensing, the company will say, "Well, do you have
patents?" And so we've been learning how to file patents for the last
20 years. But for the first one, we weren't really that experienced.
So my university actually licensed it to a company based in the UK.
And that company sat on it and thought it was useless.
So thought it was rubbish and gave it back to the university, which actually turned
out to be a very big mistake because this patent for subsequently was very
valuable.
And then, so I have to find another person who's interested.
So I remember I went to Thailand for a genetic conference and
then met this gentleman who is Dr. Charles Cantor, who at that
time was the chief scientific officer of a company called Sequenom.
So we start talking and then collaborating and eventually, actually,
Sequenom licensed our technology.
But on the other side, of course, you can imagine in Stanford, the professor is
very experienced with commercialization.
So Steve Quake actually licensed his technology to Veranara, which was
then bought by Illumina.
So now you can imagine on one side you have Illumina with the Stanford
patent, on the other side, you have Sequenom with my patent.
And so of course, they will use patent as a weapon and they fight.
So there's a series of four lawsuits.
So we won three of them, and they won one.
So eventually we decide to settle out of court, and then we basically
put all the patent into a pool, and then people who want access of this
technology can just license from pool.
So this technology is now called NIPT, non-invasive prenatal testing,
which has been actually used 100 million times, now
buy. And also it's a standard of care in the prenatal medicine.
So now we can see how I developed this technology is because I look at
the cancer work, and this inspired me to hunt for fetal
cell-free DNA in maternal plasma.
And I thought the fetal side seems to be working well, so maybe it's time for us to
actually feed this back into cancer.
So we started with a cancer called nasopharyngeal cancer, or NPC for
short, which is a cancer very common in the southern part of
China.
For example, a Cantonese man like myself, my lifetime risk of this
cancer is about one in 39.
And also another reason why we choose this cancer is because for this method to
work, I need to have a tumor-specific target which I can
use, just like the Y chromosome from baby boy.
And for nasopharyngeal cancer, we have such a target in the form of Epstein-Barr
virus DNA. So I was thinking maybe in the course of this biology, the
NPC cell will release the EBV DNA in the bloodstream, which we can use.
I still remember when I first proposed that, many of my colleagues don't believe
it'll work because they thought most of us are chronic EBV carriers.
So if you do this, it's going to have a lot of false positive.
But interesting, when we did the experiment, we find actually it's pretty good.
So on the left-hand side is in the plasma of NPC patient, is really stuffed
full of EBV DNA. On the right-hand side is healthy individuals, and
most are negative.
Then we thought, "Well, maybe we can use this technology to screen for this
cancer." So a few years ago, we did a large trial
involving over 20,000 subjects in the whole territory of
Hong Kong.
And then we focused on the high-risk group, who are males between age
of 40 and 60. And we want to see whether plasma EBV DNA can
be used to screen for this cancer.
And in the end, out of 20,000 people, we pick up 34 cases of
cancer. Now, interestingly, you can find that without screening,
most of the cases are stage III and stage IV, so 80% are in the late
stage. But now in the screen cohort, you can see they now
change to 70% in stage I and stage II.
And because it's so early, you can see the screen cohort of the 34 people we
screen, only one die. So the chance of dying is around
3%. But on the other hand, if you don't screen, the chance of
mortality is 40%. So basically, it's over a 10 times reduction
in mortality. So this work was published in "The New England Journal of Medicine,"
was chosen to be one of the 10 notable articles that year.
Of course, nasopharyngeal cancer is my first goal.
I want to be able to extend this technology to other cancer types.
But of course, not every cancer have a virus as a target.
So we try a number of different methods, and eventually we settle
down on epigenetics using DNA methylation.
So we develop a genome-wide methylation assay and show that
for the first time that one test is enough for you to screen
multiple types of cancer.
And furthermore, because different organs in our body have got
different methylation status, I can also use this technology to tell
us where is the tumor of origin.So after we have developed
these technologies, then I thought, well, this time we are little bit more
mature in our commercialization experience.
So I started together with two of my students, a company called Cerena, which stand
for circulating nucleic acid. Basically, we're trying to develop a
test which will allow us to detect cancer at the early stage, so we can do
something about that. But interesting, at the same time, Illumina just
started a company called GRAIL, and you can see the mission is very similar, to
detect cancer early when it can be cured.
So basically you can see that Cerena and GRAIL are going the same direction.
So just based on my previous experience, if that happens,
eventually we end up seeing each other in court, right?
And so this time we try to be proactive.
So in 2017, the two companies merged, and I become
a scientific co-founder of GRAIL.
And this is actually the merger party, which is the 2017
NBA Finals. So that year, of course, the Golden State Warrior won.
So this is in San Francisco, and the person next to me is a founding
CEO of GRAIL, who's a guy called Jeff Huber, who's a guy who
brought us Google Maps. And so after a few years of work, so
basically this company launched the first multi-cancer early detection test.
And of course, the field is hot heating up now because a number of other
companies have entered this area, like Exact Science,
Guardant, and many Chinese companies.
But of course, we also have some challenges.
For example, GRAIL has recently released in a press release
that in a large-scale trial of 140,000 people in the UK,
they actually missed some of the key goals.
And so as a result, in March this year, Nature actually published this
piece saying that, are those multi-cancer early detection
tests ready for prime time yet? So I think more work is
needed. So in the final part of my talk, I'm going to talk about some of the
work that we've been doing to try to push the performance
in this area. So if you look at DNA
inside the cell, they're basically chromosome length, long molecules.
But interestingly, if you look at DNA, which is in our plasma, it is
actually fragmented into millions of pieces.
And so for many years, people thought this fragmentation is random, but we and
others have shown that there's actually a pattern to this fragmentation.
So the study of this fragmentation pattern is now called cell-free DNA
fragmentomics.
And you can actually study a number of ways.
For example, you can look at the size of the molecules.
Now, for example, back to the fetal situation, if you measure
the size of fetal DNA and the mother's DNA in the mother's blood, this is what
you get. So the x-axis is the size of molecules, some 50 to 200
base pair, and the y-axis is how much of those molecules you can find.
So the fetal DNA is in blue, the total DNA, which is mainly from
mother, is in red. So we can see the fetal DNA is a little bit
shorter than the mother's DNA.
Now so we can imagine that if you take a sample, the more fetal DNA it has in
the sample, the shorter should be the size distribution.
So what that means is that you can use the size as a metric to
measure the concentration of fetal DNA.
So here you can see a positive correlation between a
size-based measurement and a genome-based measurement, which is based on
Y chromosome.
But of course, if you use the genome-based measurement, you can only do it if the
baby is a boy. But now with the size base, you can do it
irrespective of the sex of the baby.
And actually, the concentration of fetal DNA is the number one parameters
governing the accuracy of non-invasive prenatal testing.
And furthermore, you can push this even further.
Now imagine, let's say, the baby have Down syndrome.
It has an extra copy of chromosome 21, which is pushing out the
short DNA in the mother's plasma. So if you measure size distribution of
chromosome 21, compare with the other chromosomes, then you can
actually see a shortening if the baby have Down syndrome.
So now, actually we'll do a commercial non-invasive prenatal test.
Basically, they will combine the counting and the size measurement together.
Then you will say, well, how about non-pregnant subjects?
So in non-pregnant subject, this is what you get.
You got a predominant peak, which is 160 base pair, which is
a nucleosome size fragment.
And then if the patient have cancer, like liver cancer, then the higher the
cancer DNA concentration, the shorter is the size distribution.
So once again, indicating the cancer DNA in
circulation is shorter than the non-cancer DNA.
Now, in addition to measurement size, you can also look at the end structure
of the molecule, because the end could be
maybe double-strand DNA, blunt end, or maybe jacket,
protruding ends. So jacket-ness is one of the fragmentomics
marker. And you can also look at the sequence at the end, we
call end motif. So let's say you focus on the four nucleotide at
the end of molecule. So the number possibility is four to
power four. So in other words, by doing that, you split the cell-free DNA
into 256 types.
And reason we've been asking this question, is this the whole picture?
Because you can see that after those publication, many other
individuals have actually
shown that you can actually use end motif, et cetera, as a type of cancer
marker. But reason we ask, how complete is this?
The reason is because imagine you have a double strand DNA molecule here.
Because of the presence of jacket end, you have to do some sort of polishing
before you can do sequencing. And by the polishing, you
basically will extend the 3' end,
and if there's protruding 3' end, you chop it.
So what that means is basically the 3' end is
artifactual. Only the 5' end is the real
sequence. So in other words, the fragmentomics field in the literature up to
now have all based on just the 5' end.
The 3' end is unexplored. So reason we ask, is it
possible for us to develop technology which will allow us to look at the 3'
end?So we thought that one way to do that is to say that you have
a double-strand DNA in circulation, a denature, and then
use a single-strand library preparation method.
And by doing that, for the first time, we'll have a native 3'
end motif, which I can study.
So imagine now in this situation, I have a 5' end,
and then I have 3' end. So we need to give them some names.
So for this one, 5' end, I call this a 5' end motif, so
EM5, so end motif 5 prime. And now on this side,
I call this EM3, end motif 3 prime.
And of course, you can imagine this fragment has to be chopped off
somewhere from a genome. So in a genome, there will be some
sequence which is before that, so I call this pre-end motif,
PREM.
And then there's some bit which is at the other side, I
call it post-end motif, POEM.
So basically, you have these four types of new fragmentomics marker.
So next, we like to see what happens to those marker in the plasma of
healthy individual without cancer. And this is what happened.
Now, for example, you look at this particular
EM5, and here on the x-axis,
I plot all the end motif in alphabetical order, starting with A, C,
G, and T. And the y-axis is the frequency of
those motif. And you can see that EM5 has
specific features. It has an enrichment of
CN motif. And we have previously shown that the CN motif is
due to an enzyme called DNase 1-like 3.
And now we look at the PREM, and you can see that the pattern is completely
different. There's an enrichment of the T end motif.
And the yellow side, EM3, you can see the pattern.
There's enrichment of T, plus a bit of A and G.
And then POEM, you can see this enrichment of C.
So basically now you have the four types.
Now, if you look carefully, you see something very intriguing.
You can see that actually EM5 and POEM are very
similar. You can see both have this enrichment of C motif, which is these two
guys. But of course, you think about it in more detail, you can say that
the POEM is actually a EM5 of the subsequent fragment.
So it's actually logical that the two of them are correlated.
And similarly, on the other side, you can see this also have similarity.
There's an enrichment of T and also a bit of the
A.
And of course, you think about that, the PREM is basically a
EM3 of the preceding fragments.
Okay. And then we can actually plot this in a heat map.
So on the vertical axis here is basically all the end motif sequence,
and these are the four types of fragmentomics marker.
And you can see, for example, the similarity of PREM and EM3, you can see,
and similarity of EM5 and POEM. But also, when you plot it this
way, you can also very clearly see there's also some features in which
these two are similar, but there are some areas which are different, which we can
actually explore in the future.
And just now, when I talk about size, I said if you do a
double-strand DNA library preparation, you have this 160 base
pair, which is nucleosomal peak. But now, if you try to use a
single-strand library preparation, you actually have two peaks.
One is in 160, and the other one is curiously at a
50 base pair.
And now, basically, I can separately look at the fragmentomic
markers for the 50 base pair peak and also
160. So you can basically see the four type of marker, PREM,
EM5, EM3, and POEM for these two. So the message
we see is that you can see, for example, in the larger peak, the
demarcation is very sharp. But here in the lower peak, it's less sharp.
Probably means that as the DNA got degraded more and more, basically, all
this, the more and more process got involved, and so they become
fussier.
And then next question you ask, how about can I use those type of
fragmentomic markers for cancer liquid biopsy?
So basically, what we've got now, we have this four series.
So look at individual with liver cancer and without liver cancer.
And now we plot volcano plot for each of these four classes of fragmentomic
markers. And the red ones are the over-represented in liver cancer,
and the blue one are under-represented in cancer.
You can clearly see that you can use that as a cancer liquid biopsy
marker.
And then here is showing a series of area under the
ROC curve, in which you can see that by combining different
amount, you actually have gradual increase in diagnostic performance.
So up to now, I've shown you a number of new fragmentomics marker.
And recently, we also ask, is this the whole pattern, whole picture?
The reason why I say that is because you can imagine you have a double strand DNA
molecule in the circulation floating around, and they have them
sequencing method. But all of the sequencing method have one thing in
common, is that the Watson and Crick strand are separated,
and then basically, you lost the connection information.
It's almost like you have a pair of gloves, and you put into a washing machine,
and basically, the washing machine will wash those gloves separately.
So I'm thinking, wouldn't it be nice if I'm able to
actually
measure this double-strand DNA molecule as a whole?
That will change the fragmentomics field from 1D to
2D.
And I thought one way to do that is somehow you have a chain which
link the two member of the gloves together.
So what we did is develop a series of stem-loop primers,
and then we attach onto the end, and the
stem-loop length varies, depends on the length of the jacket
edge, jacket ends, and then they are bar-coded.
And then if it is perfect ligated, we have this basicallyA ring
type of structure. If it's not, then we can digest it
away with exonuclease. And then we can basically sequence this by
Pacific Bioscience system.
And now with this sort of structure, then we need a new type of nomenclature,
because imagine now we have this two-dimensional double-strand
DNA molecule in a circulation, which we can measure with four
ends. And so we thought the one way is to do a
nomenclature with this line, separate the two strand, the Watson strand and
Crick strand, and the arrow is a five prime to three prime, and then can
basically write the end motif that way.
And by doing this, for example, we can say the sequence of the end motif
or how many end motif you're looking at, so only one nucleotide, so
one, one, one, one, et cetera. And there are many types of variations.
And we call this holistic end motif analysis.
An exciting thing about that is now many people are putting in this sort of
sequencing data into foundation model to be trained.
But normally, of course, you only have A, C, T, G.
But now, suddenly with this concept, you have more than four possibility,
because imagine if it's double-strand DNA, you can call it A, C, T, G.
If one side is protruding, you can call it A prime, C prime, T prime, et
cetera. If it's receding, then call it A double prime, T double prime, et
cetera. So instead of having four possibility, A, C, T, G, you now have 12.
And this, for example, by using just one from each of the end,
we were able to actually separate the liver cancer and control from the
plasma very well.
And this is actually to show the combination from the usual
EM5 all the way up to the one, one, one, one.
And furthermore, this method is very efficient in terms of the number of molecules
you need. You can see with a few thousand molecules, you already have over
performance over what you have in the field.
So finally, in conclusion, I hope I've convinced you circulating DNA analysis
has created a number of paradigm shift in medical diagnostics.
And one interesting thing is the similarities between pregnancy and cancer.
And NIPT is already a standard of care in obstetrics and there are emerging
applications in cancer screening.
But more work is needed on fundamental biology like fragmentomics.
So finally, I'd like to thank individual from my group for generating the results
which are shown today, and thank you very much for your time.
Thank you,
Professor Lo. What an amazing story.
I love how everything started and
that photograph of
Dr. Quirk from Stanford, and it's just meant to be, right?
I mean, the fact that he was in that photograph with you at your Oxford
graduation ceremony,
and your wife as well, it just blows my mind.
If anyone has any questions, please either submit them via the
QR code or please make your way up to the mic.
I'm just wondering, obviously, cdDNA in oncology
for us has really
changed our practice. It really has.
Even in drug development, we're not just using it as a
diagnostic, but also to track patients, but also now as a
pharmacodynamic biomarker in drug development.
It is still, obviously, it's blood, so it's slightly,
relatively minimally invasive, but how about
other tissue? Because we've actually now started to do it in CSF, and it
actually works pretty well. Have you thought about saliva or any other
tissue as well, just going beyond blood?
We have worked on CSF as well, and which works.
And then, of course, in urine for urological type of condition
like prostate cancer, bladder cancer, et cetera.
I think the saliva and even sweat, those are worth
looking at, but I think there's very few data on that.
Yeah. Thank you. We've got a question there.
Yeah. George Weiner from Iowa. Fantastic work.
Given the short half-life, what do you know about heterogeneity and
diurnal variation as far as the amount of
cell-free DNA that you find in the blood if you test it five minutes apart,
10 minutes apart, two hours apart from the same patient?
Okay, thank you.
Now, so actually, this is an important question.
Actually, interestingly, the first
study in the field about this diurnal variation,
they actually, in the end, the result was artifactual because they actually
forgot about the importance of pre-analytical procedures, like
how much you spin to get rid of all the cell, et cetera.
So in the literature, you see actually some early work in which people talk
about a lot of diurnal variation. So I would say that we would take those data
with a pinch of salt. But since then, actually, people have looked
at
what sort of conditions will affect that.
And what I would say is that in the literature, for example, more convincing would
be like exercise. If somebody over the course of a day did some
relatively strenuous exercise, they would change the
level of cell-free DNA.
And then also in the obstetric field, people have
looked at, for example, like the menstrual cycle.
I've also looked at some
medical therapeutics type area. For example, if you would have dialysis, they will
change the level of cell-free DNA.
I think basically more work is needed in that area.
Yeah.
But what I can say is that, for example, nasopharyngeal cancer, we have also done
that following people during the course of radiotherapy, in which we actually
sample them every day. And we find that this predominant signal we see
is that of by the radiotherapy rather than by the diurnal variation.
Thank you.
Professor Mack?
Yeah. Dennis, this is fascinating.
I mean, what you talked about
It's not in textbooks.
So my question is that in
case of viral-related cancers like EBNA1
for EBV, is there a
particular sequence you can look for, or for
HPV, you're looking for E6 and E7?
But your method is just
pan-nucleic acid biochemistry.
Yes. Thank you.
So for the EBV genome,
what we've looked at is actually looked at the methylation profile
because a different latency status of EBV, they associate different methylation
status. And this is one way in which you can further cut down
the false positive rate of this type of screening.
And I think the similar thing you can also do it for human papillomavirus.
We have also looked at the fragmentomics profile of the virus DNA, and
they have a very interesting fragmentomics as well.
I think what you're saying about maybe in the future people can look at RNA as
well. Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah. All right.
Dr. Lo, congratulations for the extremely
inspiring achievement for your career.
Actually, I'm Fabio Pitella from University of Brazilian, Brazil,
and I would like to ask what's your
thoughts about using the histone information in the
nucleosome that carries the ctDNA around to better
stratify all the cancer markers and
have more idea about the
clinical outputs of the histone markers?
Thank you very much. So we have actually recently looked at the
histone modifications to see whether they change the
fragmentomic status, and the answer is yes.
So it seems that the histone modification, methylation,
acetylation, et cetera, will change maybe the
interaction between the DNA part and the histone, which will result in whether
nuclease can access it or not. And also in the literature,
Sadehl, S-A-D-E-H-L, from Jerusalem,
has done a ChIP-seq from the cell-free DNA.
So that's another area we can explore. So thank you.
In the middle.
Hi, great talk. Thank you very much. I'm Leah from USC.
I have a question for the last development.
I kind of missed a step that this is
fragments
linked into long fragments and going into PacBio, or it
is
like RCA amplified going into PacBio.
So basically, I'm trying to think of a way in which you
can originally have a double-strand DNA by putting in the
dumbbell shape link at the end, whether you
can directly sequence it. And as you know, of
course, the PacBio sequencing is exactly that.
So basically, we put all the necessary bit for PacBio into
that structure. So that's why
that is a PacBio-based system.
But of course, we also know that with PacBio, the disadvantage is
that the number of molecules you can sequence is low.
And so that is the reason why in the example I showed you just now, I use 1111
because I don't have enough molecules.
So now we're actually working on developing an Illumina-based version of
that. And that, if it's successful, then I think this
will allow us to increase the throughput and then train some
LLM. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
We have time for two more questions, so on the left and then on the right.
Congratulations. A great talk, Dr. Lo.
I have a question about your
fragmentomics. One is,
are you able to
compare the specificity of
fragmentomics with the
biomarker, the in vitro,
non-invasive detection, the specificity?
Are you able to identify the cancer
originated, particularly from which tissue?
Just compare your example, NPC or HCC.
Second,
between those
different cancer from different tissues, the
fragmentomics, the profile has
a difference. Are you able to tell?
Okay, thank you. The answer is yes.
Different tissue, they have different fragmentomic profiles.
And one of the reasons is because the fragmentation pattern is actually
associated by the methylation status.
So because, for example, 5-methylcytosine methylation
will actually change the angle of the double
helix,
making it
more accessible to external nuclease.
So basically, what we've done is we developed a technology called FRAGMA,
F-R-A-G-M-A, Fragmentomics-based Methylation Analysis.
By using that relationship, you can tell whether a
particular CpG site is methylated or not.
So if you look at tissue-specific methylation CpG,
then combined with that fragmentation profile, it can tell you where it is.
And secondly, of course, is what I mentioned just now, the histone modification
is also tissue-specific, and you can also do that as well. Thank you.
All right, final question.
Hi, Dr. Lo. My name's Lucas Penny from the University of Toronto.
Really fascinating work all around. Very impressive.
Curious about the EBV work that you have, incredible story
on for the past 10 years. From the fragmentomics perspective, do you see
similar patterns with human fragments versus viral fragments?
And are the same shorter fragment and cancer
relationships still there, or do you see differences?
It's the same thing as a human. Basically, I think the EBV,
after it got into the cell, they basically take on the histone, the
chromatin structure. So the NPC patients'
EBV is basically about 20 base pairs shorter than the
normal DNA.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Professor Lo, thank you very much and many
congratulations on your election.
Thank you everyone for being here. I'll bring this session to a close. Thank you.